ก็
สวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะถ้านักเรียนอาสวัสดีค่ะจูฟ้าจาน
สวัสดีค่ะผู้หญิงหานักเรียนค่ะมือ
เลยกับเราสองคน
แล้ว
บีกินเนอร์นะคะบีจะเริ่ดคว้าสถาใส่ค่ะ
อะไรพี่ครูฟ้าดูไม่เหมือนเดิม
อะไรอ่ะกูฟ้าก็คือป๊าไงกูป่าวกูป่าแต่
ทุกครั้งที่เจอกันครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีแว่นตาแม่
ครูหญิงเนี่ยใส่แว่นตาคุณอย่างนี้นั่นตา
ครูปลาก็มีทำไมวันนี้ไม่มีแว่นตาไม่ใส่
แว่นตามี
นิสัยแว่นใช้เพราะว่า
กูป่ะเนี่ยมีแว่นปากดูคนอ่า
ทำไมไม่ใส่
เพราะว่า
เล่นมันอยู่นี่นะฮะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
แว่นตานะคะแว่นตาแต่
1  5 เนี่ยไม่มีเล็งถึงป่ะ
เพราะเลนส์อยู่ที่นี่หาเลนส์นะเอม
เลนหามันหลุดออกมานะคะครูบาก็ไม่ใส่แว่น
นะโอเคนะใส่ไม่ได้นะคะไม่โอเคอ้าวแล้ว
ไม่ใส่แว่นป๋าไม่เป็นไร
แล้วครูฟ้ามองเห็นหรอคะตาครูฟ้าแบบมอง
เห็นไหมไม่ใส่แว่นตาแอบ
มองไม่เห็นนะ
มานั่งตรงนี้ใช่ไหมนี่นั่งแล้วมองเนี่ย
โอ้โห
มองไม่เห็น
ต้องเข้าไปอ้ามองเห็น
ต้องใกล้ไปต้องใกล้ๆค่ะใช่
แบบนี้ก็แต่โอเคโอเคขวาเนี่ยมองผู้หญิง
50% ค่ะมองหวิงก็โอเคค่ะจ่ายเพราะว่าตา
ใช่มั้ยตาเนี่ยอย่างถ้าเมื่อก่อนกูฟ้าใส่
แว่นตาก็จะมองเห็น
100% ใช่น้า
ก็ไม่ใส่โอเคไม่ใส่
กิเลสาถ้าไม่มีเล่นได้ค่ะเพราะว่าเนาะอา
ใช่ไหมคะตาเนี่ยน้องต๋าครูฟ้ามีตาใช่ไหม
คะกูฟ้ามีตาค่ะมีตาเท่าไหร่
1  2 ใช้ฟ้ามีตา 1
2 ฟ้ามีปลาสองข้างค่ะ
ป่า 2 บาทผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงนะคะ
2 ค่ะของ 2 บนหน้าผากไม่มีตาไม่มีมี
122 ตาสองข้างเหมือนลุงป้าน้า
เหมือนกันค่ะก็ปลาข้างซ้ายตาข้างขวานะคะ
ใจมีตาสร้าง App อาซ่าขอให้ตาขวา
นักเรียนก็มีตา 2 ข้างเหมือนกัน
[เพลง]
1122 นะคะมี 3 เนาะไม่มีไม่มีไม่มี 3
ลาย
ที่ไม่มีไม่มีสองตาสองข้างทางใต้ตาเอาไว้
ทำอะไรคือฟ้า
ตาเอาไว้
มองเอาไว้ดูขาเหมือน
มองดู
เหมือนตอนนี้นักเรียนเนี่ยดูวีดีโอสมัย
YouTube ดูเราสองคนก็ใช้ตาดูดู
วีดีโอภาษา
หัวหน้านักเรียนนักเรียนนักเรียนใช้ตา
เนี่ยดู
วีดีโอนะคะถ้าเกิดหลับตาก็ดูไม่ได้
จ่ายนั้นลืมตา
ลืมตาดูได้เกาะดูดาวคิดได้รูปร่างบาง
ครั้งนักเรียนก็ใช้ตาตาดูทีวีไทยดูทีวี
ครูฟ้าดูทีวีไหมคะดูค่ะภาษาเนี่ยนิตาดู
ทีวีดูเน็ตลิคไง YouTube ดูดิสนีย์นี้มี
Disney ดีหรือ Plus ดีว่าดูการ์ตูนอะไร
วะนี้ดูเราใช้ตาแม้มีตากใช้ตาดูทีวีตาย
ถ้าไม่มีตาก็แต่กูไม่ได้ๆลืมตาเลยนะ
รับตาเนี่ยดูไม่ได้ต้องดื่มตาใส่แล้วลืม
ตาก็สัตว์ดูว่าตาเอาไว้ดูไม่ทุกคนมีตาไว้
ดูอือแต่ก็นักเรียนเรียนกับเราเนี่ยสองคน
ต้องใช้ตาดู
อ่าในการดูแล้วก็ใช้
หูอ่ะหนูคะหู
เฮ้ยกูมามีหนึ่งหูหรอผมครับผมคุณปิดอยู่
ค่ะเปิดค่ะเปิด
เปิดหูค่ะครูป๊า
ผู้หญิงมีหูเท่าไหร่คะผู้หญิงมีหู 2 หู
ทั้งสองข้างเนาะมีหูต๊ายมีซ้ายกูหญิงหู
ขวามี 2 รูปฟ้ามีหูเท่าไหร่คะครูฟ้าก็มี
หู 2 ข้างค่ะอันนี้ใช่มั้ย
1-2
มีหู 2 ข้างของกูมาเนี่ยหูซ้าย
อันนี้หูฝาอามีหู 2 ข้างนะคะซ้ายหูขวา 1
ซ้ายตาขวา
พูดเหมือนกันอ่าใส่อ่ะหนู
สายตาเนี่ยตาน้องตาเราเอาไว้ดูแล้วหนูทำ
อะไร
หูเราเอาไว้ฟังค่ะทำฟังฟังอะไรบ้างครูฟ้า
อ่ะสีฟ้าเนี่ยฟังเพลงนะ
อ่าจิงกะเบลจิงกะเบล
สิ่งร้อน way
you  Much  More ย-ธเพลงฉันฟังเพลง
Taylor  Swift  you  know  My  Craft
โอ๋
ใช้หูฟังเหอะถ้านักเรียนเนี่ยใช้ตาดูเรา
แล้วก็จะใช้หูฟังภาษาไทยที่เราสองคนพูด
ชายหูเนี่ยใช้ปางขาฟัง vario บางคนก็มี
วีดีโอใช่มั้ยก็ฝากค่ะหวัง with  a  f  m
a  m
ฟังเพลง
[เพลง]
ภาคไม่มีหูก็ฟังไม่ได้ฟังไม่ได้ก็ไม่ได้
นะเพราะสายฝั่ง
หายไปครั้งเอาไปตาดูฟังอย่าอย่างที่สาม
ที่ทุกคนมีเหมือนกัน
ก็คือ
สมุกนัดจมูก
จมูกมีเท่าไหร่หนึ่งค่ะไม่จมูก 1 จมูก 1
1 นะจะมีอันนึงหนึ่งอันเราเรียกว่าอัน
จมูก 1
1 อันอยู่ตรงกลางใจว่าตาจับหูเนี่ยมี
ซ้ายแล้วก็ขวาแต่จมูกมีหนึ่ง
อ้ะจะตาเอาไว้ดูหูเอาไว้ฟังแล้วจมูกทำ
อะไรคะครูป๊า
หายใจค่ะอ่าก็
หายใจอ่ะมีออกซิเจนใช่ไหมออกค่ะเช่น
คาร์บอนไดออกไซด์
ออกซิเจนเนี้ยหายไซ
ชายแล้วก็จมูกยังทำได้อีกจังนึงก็คือดม
ใช่ไหมเวลาได้กลิ่นไหนดมสิคะปากกาครูฟ้า
มีปากกา 5
เป็นยังไงคะขอหอมหรือว่า
เหม็น
เหม็นอ้ะ
หือประการเนี่ยมั้ยปากกาเหม็น
แต่ถ้า
อันนี้กูหญิงมีอันนี้กูฟ้า
อะไรคะถ้าเป็นน้ำหอมน้ำหอมอ่ะผู้ชม
Channel ชั้น L อันนี้อะไรไม่รู้แหละ
ยิวโอ๊ยแนวหน้าน้ำน้ำหอมเนี่ยเวลาดม
หอมหอมหอม
[เพลง]
หายวัดอันจมูกเป็น
จมูกเนี่ยเอาไว้ดมใช้ว่าหอมหรือเหม็น
หอม
หายใจ
นกจมูกได้ทำได้ 2 อย่างเนาะไข่หนึ่ง
ดมจม
เวลาแบบคู่ฟ้ากับผู้หญิงเนี่ยสอนอยู่แล้ว
ก็
ได้กลิ่น pizza
ข้อของหิวอยากกิน
ไม่มีของนะคะหรือว่ากินอะไรที่เหมือน
ประกามอันนี้มึงด่าเวลาดม
เหม็น
เหม็นจ่ายแต่ถ้าได้กลิ่น pizza กลิ่นส้ม
ตำกลิ่นสปาเก็ตตี้เนี่ยโหผมสวยผอมแล้วก็
คิวท้อง
หิวๆอยากกินเหนื่อยแล้วเวลาเนี่ยกิน
พิซซ่า
อร่อย
อร่อยอร่อยแล้วอะไรบอกเราว่าอร่อยอ่ะ
และลิ้นเออก็อยากแลบลิ้นเนาะ
ลิ้นใช่มั้ยอ่ะอารินลิ้น
ทุกคนมีลิ้นเนาะค่ะมิ้นต์หาคู่ค้ามีลิ้น 1
ลิ้นให้นะ 1 นะ 1 หลิน 1 อันผู้หญิงมี
ลิ้นเฮ่าไหร่ฮะหนึ่งค่ะผู้หญิงก็มีลิ้น
1 อัน
เวลาที่เรากินอาหารสมัยกินพิซซ่าหน้าลิ้น
ลิ้นก็จะบอกเราว่าอร่อยหรือไม่อร่อย
หน้าหรือว่าทุเรียนนะฮะ
you  man ใช่มั้ยทุเรียนกู้ไฟล์เนี่ย
ลิ้นขวัญได้บอกว่าอ้าอร่อยเวลา in
ทุเรียนนะเวียนหัว
[เพลง]
หิวมากไม่ครูหญิงเนี่ยทุเรียนเนี่ยลิ้น
บอกว่าไม่อร่อยจมูกก็บอกว่าเหม็น
บกหอมค่ะ
หอมกินน่ะ
[เพลง]
ก็อยู่อ่ะไม่อร่อย
ไม่เหมือนกันจ่ายสินฟ้าเนี่ยลิ้นลิ้นบอก
อร่อยลิงค์ผู้หญิงแน่บ่ไม่อะไรอร่อยนะแต่
ลิ้นจะบอกเราใช่ไหมอร่อยไม่อร่อย
ใช่ค่ะเรียนก็เหมือนกันและ pizza ลิ้นครู
หญิงบอกอร่อย
ครูฟ้าพิซซ่าที่ออกนี้เหมือนกันต้องหา
หร่อยไปค่ะน้องอัญเรามีตาเอาไว้ดูน้องหนู
เอาไว้ฟัง
จมูกเนี่ยหายใจแล้วก็ๆดมกลิ่นอ่ะและลิ้น
รับรสใช่ไหมคะบอกว่าอร่อยหรือไม่อร่อย
หรือเผ็ดเผ็ด
ใช่มั้ยอาไทยเนี่ยนักเรียนนักเรียนบอกว่า
ต้มยำกุ้งนะคะต้มยำกุ้งฟูคุ้ม
คนไทยก็เผ็ดนะใช่หาผิดเหมือนกันอันนี้
ลิ้นจะบอกเราจะไม่เรามีหนึ่งตาดู
2 หูฟัง
3 จมูก
กลิ่นเหม็นหอมหน่า 4 ลิ้น
อร่อยไม่อร่อยค่ะ
ใส่ทุกคนมีเหมือนกันถ้า
ค่าอะไร
มีอะไรๆครูฟ้า
หนึ่งตาดู 2 หูฟัง 3 จมูกดมกลิ่น 4
ลิ้นมาให้อร่อย
ปริณาห์อลิน
ประยุงหนังหนังหรอ
ใช่ไหมเวลาครูฟ้าร้อน
เทศไทยร้อน
ร้อนใช้เราเข้าใจร้อนจากผิวใช่ไหมหิว
เฮ้ยหรือ
หนาวใช่ไหมเวลากรูฟ้าหนาวฟ้าก็ฝาใส่เสื้อ
แขนสั้นแล้วหนาวซอยกูฟ้าก็จะหนาวคุณป้าก็
ต้องใส่เสื้อแล้วก็ปิดสมัยปิด
ห่มผ้าอ่ะผมมีนี้ผิวกูฟ้าก็ไม่หนาวเพราะ
ว่าผิวก็จะบอกว่าอ๋อไม่หนาวแล้วฉันอยาก
เมาแล้ว
565 หรือเวลาร้อน
ซอยก็ต้องเอาออก
หัวร้อน
ต้องจ่ายแต่ก็จะเป็นผิวหนังใช่ไหมคะผิว
หนังหรือว่าผู้หญิงเนี่ยไม่ชอบครูฟ้าตี
ครูฟ้าเกาะออก
สมัยก่อนจะเข้าใจกูว่าจะเข้าใจเจ็บผิว
หนังร้อนผิวหนังหนาวผิวหนังสมัยบอกว่าทุก
คนทุกคนทุกคนคนไทยคนอเมริกาคนยุโรปคนจีน
คนญี่ปุ่นก็จะมีเหมือนกัน 5 อย่างคือก็
คือก็ตื่นตาหมายหนึ่งตาคะค่ะเอาไว้ดูดู
ทีวีดูยูทูป
2 หู
หูเอาไว้ฟัง
ฟังฟังๆฟังภาษาไทยเราให้น่าฟัง
FM วีดีโอ
ฟังใส่บาตรนะสามจมูกจมูกเอาไว้ดมเมล์หรือ
ว่า
ขอของเธอว่าหายใจใช่ไหมสายค่ะออกเช่น
ออกซิเจนมึงได้ค่ะจะแล้วก็ 4 สี่ก็คือ
ลิ้น
ช่วยเอาไว้เข้าใจว่าเวลาที่เรากินเนี่ย
โอ้
เพชร
หรืออร่อยหรือ
ไม่อร่อยให้กินหน่อยมีทุเรียนไม่อร่อย
ทุเรียนอร่อยไม่ใคร
แล้วก็สวย 5 ก็คือห้างหนังค่ะเอาไว้อ๋อ
หนาวชายรู้สึกหลังสึกหนาว
ร้อนหรือว่าโอ๊ย
เจ็บไหมเจ็บก็คือผิวหนังมันเป็นนัก 5
อย่างไรๆทิฟทุกๆคนมีเหมือนกันใช่อ่าฉาย
ค่ะก็เป็นตาดูหูฟัง
จมูกดมกลิ่น
หินรับรถผิวหนังรู้สิน่ะนาอยู่รังสิตทั้ง
หมดนะผิวหนังใช่ค่ะ
หิวหนัง
ทั้งตัวทั้งตัวเราเป็นผิวหนังผิวหนังนั้น
คะอันนี้นะนะ
หนังมันๆหนัง
เวลาหยิบ
เจ็บใช่ไหมค่ะคือผิวหนังบอกเราขาหน้าคอ
ทั้งหมดเป็นผิวหนังผิวในชั้น
ผิวหนังนะจ่ายขาก็เป็นห้าอย่างใช่ไหมที่
จะบอกเราน้องตาดูหูฟังจมูกดมกลิ่นลิ้นรับ
รสผิวหนังรับความรู้สึก
ชายอาญานะคะพี่มันไทยทุกๆคนมีเหมือนกัน
ใช้แต่ถ้าสานักเรียนอาจจะเรียกไม่เหมือน
เราเพราะว่าภาษาไทยบอกว่าตาหูจมูก
ลิ้นเราก็ผิวหนังไม่รู้ว่าภาษานักเรียน
พูดอะไรน้องแต่นี่คือภาษาไทยนะคะผมก็วัน
นี้เราสองคนก็หมดเวลาแล้วหมดเวลาภาษานัก
เรียนก็อย่าลืมกด like กด Share กด
Subscribe นะฮะหรือว่าเปิด Notification
ด้วยนะคะไทยแลนด์วันนี้เราสองคนเถอะไทย
แล้วก็
เราไปยูทูปเบอร์
เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนแล้วเจอกันวีดีโอหน้าน้า
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะอ่า